(whistle)
- Football is the most
popular sport in Sierra Leone.
And in the city of Freetown,
there is one very special team.
Meet the Flying Stars.
Mohamed grew up playing football.
But when he was only 10 years
old he stepped on a landmine
and had to have his right leg amputated.
And unfortunately, Mohamed isn't alone.
Every member of the Flying
Stars has lost limbs
as a result of the violence that occurred
during the Civil War in Sierra Leone.
But the players don't let their injuries
stop them from getting into the game.
Not only is it a competitive sport,
it is helping them cope
with their injuries
and overcome the stigma
that's associated with the disabled.
And what better way than football.